يعرف الرجل الذي خبر السياسه طويلا ان
هؤلاء محوريون
يحدثهم عن ما يجذبهم فيكلمهم عن
الاكتشافات التقنيه وعن ملامح المستقبل
يحاول ايضا مع جيل الالفيه فكلا المرشحين
يسعى لاشتذاب الكتله الشابه التي تكاد
التوقعات تجعلها الرقم الاصعب في هذه
الانتخابات
طالبه جامعيه لكنها تنشط في احد الفروع
الشبابيه لحزب الشعب قابلناها على هامش
نشاط انتخابي فكان اغلب ما تنقمه على
اردوغان هو الوضع الاقتصادي
ولن ترى تركيا طيله حياه غير هذه الحكومه
ولذا نحتاج الى التغيير لا احب الوضع
الحالي ولا ارى مستقبلا براقا امامي ادرس
الطب لكنني افكر في السفر الى الخارج
عمر فاروق واحد من خمسه ملايين من الشباب
سيصوتون للمره الاولى وجدناه في خيمه
الانتخابيه للعداله والتنميه فحدثنا عن
سعادته باكماله 18 عاما قبيل الانتخابات
باسابيع
هذه الانتخابات ومحوريه حزب العداله
والتنميه حقق قفزات تقنيه هائله ولا بد من
اعاده انتخاب اردوغان لتستمر التنميه لقد
وضع الحزب خططا للنهضه بتركيا من ان يواصل
مسيرته لجعل بلادنا من اكثر بلدان العالم
نموا
نصف سكان تركيا تحت الثلاثين عاما وهو جيل
تربى في كنف العداله والتنميه ولم يرث
تركيا الفقيره الاقل ديمقراطيه تركيا التي
راها اباؤهم ولذا يرى انصار الحزب الحاكم
ان التحدي هو تذكير هذا الجيل بما كانت
عليه البلاد من قبل بينما يرى انصار
المعارضه ان هذه الكتله محوريه للتغيير
لعدم انشغالها اصلا باي نغمات من الماضي
الى قسمين اوروبي واسيوي وتقسم السياسه
شباب تركيا هذه الايام الى اتجاهين مؤيد
لاردوغانا ومؤيد
لكنه ما تخبئه امواج السياسه العاتيه لا
يمكن التنبؤ به احمد فار للدينة الجزيره
اسطنبول